desde montreal un saludo cordial de
parte del equipo latinoamericano de
radio canadá internacional a todos
nuestros oyentes e internautas que están
acompañándonos en este momento a través
de facebook a través de youtube y
también dentro de unos segundos a través
de nuestro sitio web eres en este punto
o sea es un gran placer tenerlos a
ustedes todos hombres en esta mesa muy
bien rodeada de testosterona es acto
damos bienvenida entonces a luis laborda
hola luisa de muy bueno siempre un
placer
pablo gómez barrios quien tal gusto y le
empleó nardo gimeno aquí a mi derecha
bienvenido entonces ya estamos
prácticamente se siente pues en canadá y
me imagino que en todas partes del mundo
estos aires de fiesta
si lo pones de nieve cosas raras que
pasan en albert donde lleva a los temas
musicales que eran escuchados en algún
momento y que ahora son rechazados
también vi que una canción estaba a
estar prohibida está prohibido
ahí ya radios que decidió no pasado un
tema musical no recordará el título pero
era uno de los cinco de vida en los eeuu
hace años atrás en este corazón es la
canción nueva con la canción ahora pero
como se trata de un hombre que intenta
que una mujer no se vaya de su casa
esta es invitada en la casa de este
hombre es quiere irse al departamento y
como afuera hace mucho frío
el frío como argumento para que ella no
se retire y bueno ha habido grupos ahora
que han acusado a la letra de la canción
de ser el sexista de hablar de acoso y
es un ir si quiere ir y el tipo la
aguanta dice no no no no te vayas y todo
lo demás
bueno y entonces se quieren prohibir esa
canción está prohibida pero por otros
lados están pues des prohibiéndose otras
cosas
leonardo estabas comentarios sobre
escuché una ley que existía en eeuu
antiquísima también más acto una ley que
en realidad circunscribe solamente a una
localidad en un estado no me acuerdo en
donde eeuu pero que en la cual él se
decía esta ley le decía que no se podían
arrojar cosas inclusive estaba apenado
por la parálisis y multa hasta hasta
podía llegar a ir dependiendo de qué es
lo que arrojaba arrojar cosas no tirar
cosas al piso sino arrojar de cosas a
alguien exacto arrojarse arlía
exacto pero eso que implicaba implicaba
que no se podían tirar bolas de nieve
en este lugar parece que nieva bastante
así que debe hacerse dentro de eeuu
centros de eeuu y resultó que después de
87 años de vigencia de esta ley
ayer fue revocada y porque como fue la
cosa que un niño empezó con esta
historia que empezó a juntar firmas y
que empezó a bueno justamente no se
puede jugar con no se puede hacer guerra
de nieve entonces no se tiene una logró
recolectar las firmas la primera la
primera bola de nieve tirada en esa
localidad donde estaba prohibido fue
ayer y si le tiró este niño al alcalde
de la ciudad que fue el que a cero la
ley actual que derogó la increíble estas
cosas bueno pero más interesante aún me
parece esta historia pablo que vos nos
preparaste que en contraste el que
sucede justamente en la provincia
canadiense de alberta y es una historia
de navidades
y que se concluyó de alguna forma este
este jueves ayer resulta de que es un
tipo de este de alberta que recibió un
regalo hace 47 años de la novia que
tenía en ese entonces y resulta de que
ésta era la novia primera novia que
tenía en casa entonces ella le entregó
el regalo de navidad un poco día antes
días antes de la navidad le entregó ese
regalo hace 47 años pero después de que
le entregó el regalo le anunció que la
relación estaba terminada caracteriza al
regalo
el regalo le dijo le dio la mala noticia
en los 18 entonces los primeros amores
en todo caso no y el tipo pues se fue
su casa todo acongojado mandó el regalo
debajo del árbol de navidad que tenía en
su casa y nunca lo abrió a los 47 años y
por ahí hay una foto que yo puse del
regalo todo bajado porque todos los años
el tipo hoy está casado con dos hijos y
desde entonces siempre aunque con con su
nueva pareja y todos ponía el regalo ese
de navidad que había tenido en aquella
época debajo del arbolito de navidad
pero nunca lo abrió y otro amigo común a
las dos personas los puso en contacto
por facebook a esa antigua pareja y se
reunieron 47 años después y porque esa
noticia salió el año pasado y le dio la
vuelta al mundo y fue publicada en los
diarios y estados como algo insólito no
de que hubo el tipo nunca abrió el
regalo entonces que se encontraron ayer
en un en un lugar en toronto en un
restaurante y la primera noticia
leonardo que sí y de y bueno pues y
finalmente ella abrió para él ese regalo
al que cuando lo abrió no podía creer
que yo hubiera comprado ese regalo
porque era un pequeño libro que para
muchos de nuestra edad se recortarán
ss
ella era la novia de siete años más
tarde entonces esa foto fue tomada ayer
justamente y es que los hombres se
achican más rápido
lo interesante de eso es que él está
legal este evento en particular ese
evento de ayer mira y los estados ese
año este evento permitió recaudar fondos
para la oficina navideña del mundo
qué es un organismo de beneficencia
local y ofrece cenas de navidad para las
familias necesitadas qué buena obra
exacto en el marco de esa actividad se
presentó 47 años más tarde la señora y
le abrió el regalo al y no hubo
electricidad
bueno no sé la historia nuestra noticia
no lo dice si hubo o no electricidad ah
caramba qué historia y el libro que
decía es un libro de datos de amores que
define amores talcos amores tantos
por eso yo lo que le quiso decir cuando
les regaló el libro y después le dijo
hasta aquí llegamos era yo no siento
esto por eso te regalo este libro para
que te des cuenta porque no te quiero
pero de ese libro hay lista de cosas que
dicen que es el amor y yo no tengo
ninguna de esta cantidad lo invento
enseguida podría ser amor es
y no olvidar cuando se rompe una
relación está perfecta
ahí están los dos amigos y se será pues
eso digo entonces no hubo electricidad
bueno
la verdad que fue interesante la
historia porque se uno siempre dice yo
siempre me espero ese tipo de historias
cuando uno lanza una botella al mar con
mensajes y se la encuentra cincuenta
años más tarde en la punta del otro
mundo pero un libro que un regalo que
nadie abrió durante 50 años quienes
estaban muy enojados
todos los años el arbolito
[Música]
muy decepcionado de la ruptura y eso es
evidente bueno hablando continuando con
el tema de navidad pues ya se está
preparando aquí es muy común en que ve
que está famoso este organismo o nariz
roja que ya empieza a activarse este
organismo pues ese creo que esta semana
empiezan las fiestas de fin de año y el
alcohol circula y entonces está todo eso
circulando libremente tanto en oficinas
donde hay fiestas como en casas en
clubes y entonces este organismo lo que
hace es ofrecer su servicio no hay un
marcador de taxi ofrecen su servicio
automovilístico para esas personas que
los llamen para que los lleven a sus
casas aparte es súper interesante porque
van dos choferes dos en cada auto porque
te van a buscar traen tu auto hasta tu
casa y ahora ellos no tienen una tarifa
pero no es voluntario
da algo de dinero y creo que ni siquiera
va para los choferes los choferes lo que
hacen es un servicio de contribución a
la sociedad y creo que eso va a
organismos de beneficencia o de ayuda
durante las navidades a la gente que no
tiene regalos para dar etcétera etcétera
pero hay muchísimas personas que acuden
a estos servicios justamente para evitar
accidentes y hablando de ayer evitar las
multas por lo cual está bien también hoy
hablando de accidentes hoy salió un
informe mundial basado en datos que
provienen de la organización mundial de
la salud que dice que la ruta es la
causa principal de muertes de jóvenes en
el mundo de 5 a 29 años y que los
accidentes viales matan a un millón 36
350.000 personas cada año lo dice lado
ms
y lo que lo que causa pues me causó
sorpresa al leer parte de este informe y
que dicen entre 5 a 29 años que no son
los chóferes ni los acompañantes en el
auto a las principales víctimas sino los
peatones y los los biciclos la gente que
va en vilo triplistas los ciclistas
entonces por qué por qué la gente o va
con toxinas en el cuerpo o va texteando
en el momento que está manejando y esto
me trae a colación algo que hizo
justamente louis esta semana y que
canadá quiere justamente reducir esos
accidentes en las rutas y están pues
proponen ciertas medidas en ontario
sobre todo así porque digamos en línea
con este informe mundial que acaba de
citar en canadá contrariamente a lo que
venía ocurriendo en los años recientes
ha habido últimamente un incremento del
número de accidentes entonces ha habido
distintas autoridades en este caso se
trata de dos departamentos policiales de
la provincia de ontario en york y en
south sign com
y decidieron tomar alguna medida para
intentar bajar este aumento progresivo
de accidentes que ha habido en los
últimos tiempos y la medida que
adoptaron es publicar en internet el
listado de personas que reciben una
multa a caramba de haber violado normas
de tránsito bajo los efectos de
sustancias tóxicas organizaciones gente
eso es una escala que sale a alguien lo
que quieren hacer estas sustancias
tóxicas son por supuesto el alcohol
tradicional en estas fiestas lo acabas
vos mismo de decir pero también otras
sustancias tóxicas que acaban de entrar
en vigencia en los últimos tiempos y que
acaba de decir los pablos se acaba de
legalizar el uso de la marihuana
recreativa encaradas entonces la policía
teme que esta situación aumente aún más
el número de accidentes y creen que ante
la falta de éxito de las campañas de
prevención de este tipo de medidas la de
que el nombre de un infractor pueda
estar en internet visto por todo el
mundo por los compañeros de trabajo por
la
puede servir como disuasor para que las
personas no sigan las medidas de
prevención no funcionan porque los
accidentes no disminuyen a que se
adhieran 12 pero a mí me llama
particularmente la atención el hecho del
uso del teléfono al volante yo veo
constantemente todos los días que estás
entrando mensajes gente que está
conduciendo un auto apareciendo un
mensaje o enviando mensajes y la manera
en que lo hacen no se pone a si mirabas
como si directamente están con el
teléfono todo el tiempo que manejan yo
he visto a gente inclusive leer diarios
para empeorar cuando salgan estos autos
eléctricos que el auto conduce solos me
imagino yo mejoraría porque el hecho de
tóxico no influirían en el accionar del
auto pero digamos con las campañas la
misma campaña municipal terrible donde
unas escenas muy violentas de accidentes
con el cigarrillo cuando mostraban el
cáncer por ejemplo los pulmones o al
cáncer a mí eso me acuerdo que me
llamaba mucho la atención sin embargo
eso no visual de la gente no no no
entiendo por donde pasaría la cosa tal
vez esa policía en este caso tenga razón
tal vez el hecho de ver el nombre propio
en una lista que puede ser difundida
públicamente abiertamente no disuada si
es que las campañas siguen sin tener
efecto y lo que decía este informe de la
organización mundial de la salud aparte
que el país los países campeones entre
comillas donde morían más peatones eran
los países africanos quiere decir que
hay tal vez en un menor control de menos
prevención probablemente bueno yo acabo
de volver de un país en el norte de
áfrica la verdad que he visto cómo se
maneja allí y me pondría nunca al
volante una caramba porque como es
porque digamos las normas no son muy
estrictas los caminos los caminos
estaban en bastante buena condición es
una tensión yo acabo de volver de pasar
unos días en túnez me llamó la atención
la calidad del mantenimiento que tenían
los caminos pero la señalización es
pésima
en la prevención que toman los
conductores es pésima
no existe el cinturón de seguridad eso
también en américa también hay gente que
no usa todo el mundo no usa los
cinturones de seguridad los vehículos
van super cargados de gente se viaja de
cualquier manera entonces eso no es
bueno ahora mejor como decía un poco
leonardo estuvo pablo las multas son tan
elevadas que probablemente hagan a los
que bueno es que es que es difícil
porque tampoco la policía puede detener
a todo el mundo que anda con un aparato
no eso creo que eso es imposible que
puede servir de escarmiento para la
persona lamentó y ver el nombre y el ver
el nombre puede ser yo creo que eso
puede tener un efecto más disuasivo
exacto exacto de la gente tiene mucho
de mora público y perderla
alguien que esté buscando trabajo no
querrá ver su nombre publicado y que un
potencial empleador pueda ver a este
señor no cumple las normas de tránsito
por leonardo hay mensajes si tenemos un
mensaje que me llamó la atención porque
bueno lo dijimos la semana pasada en
juan carlos miranda duarte nos pone
caritas de felicidad y la pila era abril
dice saludos he descargado la nueva
aplicación de radio canadá internacional
y entonces esto nos lleva a hablar de
esta nueva aplicación que justamente
hablamos la semana pasada y que pues de
leonardo puedes explicarnos exacto y le
muestro al de él que puede acceder de
usted cuando ustedes están en el sitio
de radio que era internacional hemos
puesto en realidad todas las páginas
inclusive en la página inicial aquí
a la derecha arriba hemos puesto una
imploración donde uno puede hacer clic
ahí adentro y aparece la página qué
permite bajar la aplicación para
cualquiera de los dos
para la gente absolutamente fácil o no
hace clic y lo manda a uno directamente
al appstore en el caso de que tenga un
móvil iphone y en el caso de que tenga
un móvil que corre bajo el android
pueden bajarlo en google play y
realmente es bastante interesante porque
no solamente el hecho de la posibilidad
de que sea bastante más rápido que el
sitio internet sino el hecho de poder
guardar las cosas que no le interesan
para después poder hacerlo offline
digamos uno guarda y después lee el
contenido lamentó que la mente fuera sin
necesidad de buscarlos o diga estar en
datos para bajar ese artículo después en
la posibilidad de para aquellos como yo
que tenemos presbicia y necesitamos
lentes para leer o sacarse los lentes
para leer de cerca la posibilidad de
agrandar
y entonces tiene un montón de cosas
interesantes sobre todo en español
así que uno puede disipar de eso y bueno
toda la posibilidad también nosotros
tenemos desde radio canal internacional
de si hay alguna noticia de último
momento hacer un putsch que se le da más
es decir enviarle a la gente esa noticia
en primicia para que tenga la
información al instante el instante y en
la punta de los dedos está muy bien pues
entonces ya están informados les
recuerdo entonces que están en este
programa del castor cibernético de radio
canadá internacional también les
recuerdo que pueden escuchar este
programa a través de facebook youtube y
hereje y net punto sea la música por
ejemplo va a estar en el programa más
tarde en el bne en cuando esté
disponible ya en nuestro sitio web y hoy
destacamos la presencia de dos
canadienses que acaban de ser nominados
hoy
a los premios grammy en la canción del
año que es pues él es uno de los rubros
más importantes de los premios y hay dos
canadienses drake y yo no sé si ustedes
los conocen
pero no drake es rapero y yo lo
reconozco más en los partidos de los
raptors es fanático de los raptors de
toronto donde toronto y él está siempre
al contado veamos en uno de los sitios
más caros
saluda a los jugadores cuando salen y
los alienta constantemente realmente un
personaje no además me gusta lo que hace
es muy interesante y bueno es nominados
son los premios grammys son los más
grandes premios a la música en estados
unidos me imagino que es eso
entonces en el sitio web va a ver
justamente las canciones que por las
cuales ellos son candidatos y estos
premios grammy se entregan en el mes de
febrero si no me equivoco en los ángeles
seguimos entonces conversando con temas
que
nos llamaron la atención y a mí
particularmente también hay otro tema
que creo que es la primera vez que yo
veo algo así le sucedió a una atleta de
quebec un atleta canadiense que acaba de
recibir sus medallas sus medallas dije
bien olímpicas que las ganó diez años
más tarde es una atleta de 10 de la
provincia de québec se llama christine
girard y pablo tienes la historia porque
es una historia que llama mucho la
atención justamente porque es algo
insólito más que insólito así justo me
parece también justo bueno todo el
problema del dopaje en el deporte no
está chica esta canadiense es
levantadora de pesos o de pensar esas
eso también puede que lo levante alguien
el levantador de pesas y bueno estuvo
participando en los juegos olímpicos de
verano en pekín en el 2008
londres en el 2012 en el 2008 ella
terminó en cuarto lugar si entonces en
los tres primeros lugares fueron atletas
de países del este y de rusia bueno en
fin terminó en cuarto lugar bien en el
2000 y en el 2012 en los olímpicos de
londres ella terminó en el tercer lugar
tuvo la medalla de bronce ahora bien
este este año en el 2016 hace dos años
hicieron pruebas antidopaje a las
campeonas del oscar las que habían
terminado entre en el primer y tercer
lugar en los olímpicos de pekín debe de
pekín y la chica que había ganado la
medalla de plata resultó positiva
entonces la de bronce subió a plata y
ella que estaba en el cuarto lugar
entonces se ganó su medalla de bronce de
los olímpicos del 2008 en pekín cuando
la gente dice que un cuarto puesto no
interesa
dice que el segundo lugar es el primer
perdedor
entonces regresando a esta atleta ella
en el 2012
resulta que había terminado en tercer
lugar con la medalla de bronce pero
después de análisis de las pruebas
antidopajes resulta que la que ganó las
que ganaron el primero y el segundo
lugar no no en el mismo momento pero
después de los análisis fueron
despojadas
un tiempo hasta que su al prefiere hasta
que le dieron finalmente pues en esta en
esta semana se hizo la ceremonia en el
centro de artes de ottawa para
entregarle sus medallas su medalla de
bronce y su medalla de plata que ella
fue a recibir con sus tres niños y con
su familia y todo esto ahora bien ella
estaba muy contenta de recibir sus
medallas pero que injusticias es algo
justicia porque el momento ese momento
especial
juego olímpico es donde ella tendría que
haber recibido pero ella lo que dice más
que el momento si ella reconoce que lo
hubiera recibido en esa ceremonia pero
lo que más le duele es que el hecho de
no haber tenido sus medallas en el
momento en que ella las ganó en esos
olímpicos le lee le impidió tener
acceder a la posibilidades que le
hubieran permitido él le dice que se
entrenaba entre pekín y losa y los tres
se entrenaba en un garaje que su papá le
había arreglado y que le había puesto
una puerta y que estaba apenas con
calefacción entonces su entrenamiento
fue no fue tan activo como hubiera
debido hacerlo si hubiera obtenido sus
medallas entonces ella lo que encuentra
es más ella dice que no le tiene ningún
rencor a esas chicas
que se dopaban porque según ella ya lo
que dice es que
en muchas de esas muchachas se tomaban
lo que los médicos y los directores de
la delegación le daban y muy buenos
sabían que lo mejor era algo pero no
sabían exactamente que claro pero está
bien todo lo que está diciendo pero
fijate vos que es la primera vez en la
historia de los juegos olímpicos que una
canadiense gana la medalla de oro en la
halterofilia eso creo que haber ser eso
destacado y recibir esa medalla con
todos los honores es algo que no lo vas
a tener nunca en tu vida esas imágenes
esa emoción aparte de todo lo que ella
dice después que yo no había pensado en
eso que es una oportunidad económica
perdida
entonces se convirtió de hecho esta
semana en la primera canadiense como
decías ser campeona olímpica empresas
pues qué bien qué interesante muy bien
en toda la historia de los olímpicos por
eso también es criticable he dicho que
se ha tomado tanto tiempo para llevar a
cabo esos análisis y para tener los
resultados pues que ya no cambia nada de
todas
a futuro en las futuras competencias
alguien que quede por ejemplo en el
cuarto lugar nuevamente va a poder
mantener la angustia de no saber si
quienes están te ofrecen en el podio no
han cometido alguna infracción como ha
ocurrido en este caso cierto porque un
plazo tan largo y en el caso de que
hubiera sido por ejemplo si los juego
olímpicos fueron el 2006 y al final el
juego olímpico o el año siguiente
esta chica hubiera podido obtener
también becas o ese tipo de soporte
porque ésta estaba en competencia y es
una media vista olímpica un análisis
clínico es cuestión de minutos
ahora pero ya empiezan ahora es en
cuestión de minutos pero estamos
hablando de hace diez años estamos
hablando de londres-2012 para que no
estaba allí
y yo creo que sí
de acuerdo con la agencia mundial
antidoping 70 como genera un real y uno
de los grandes impulsores para para
controlar este justamente de que no se
para
los atletas logren tener premios cuando
no corresponde por doping y otras cosas
es dick pound que es un canadiense un
abogado canadiense que está al frente de
toda esta lucha anti anti doping en los
juegos y yo creo que las cosas estoy de
acuerdo se podrían haber hecho un
poquito más rápido son ya son seis años
en total
en total muchísimo tiempo y pobre esta
atleta pero al mismo tiempo pues uno ve
la cara de ella con las dos medallas muy
feliz qué alegría no pues qué alegría
sin bueno a mí lo que me la muestras la
atención un poco esta semana también es
que es la salida al espacio del
conquense canadiense que fue al espacio
encuentro ahora ya está ya tranquilo
porque me dio y lo interesante de aparte
de todo lo que eso significa en
investigación científica para canadá
porque es hay que decir estos
astronautas tienen formación
extraordinaria durante el doctor creo
que se preparó son que físicos químicos
médicos en fin de todo
ya que es médico astrofísico e ingeniero
no por eso y además de tener todo eso
esa formación que tiene lo preparan como
para ir al espacio durante él estuvo
creo que durante en un entrenamiento
hace seis años ininterrumpido en rusia
en eeuu con las lenguas que hablan
porque además tiene que hablar con su
colega ruso todos ellos hablan idiomas
varios idiomas
la actual gobernadora general de canadá
es julie payette de ella antes de eso
fue astronauta y habla español muy bien
y hablar ruso y no sé qué otras español
hecho si te ahora lo lo intentamos traer
aquí al programa y varias gestiones uno
de los representantes de la agencia
espacial canadiense terminó diciendo que
si bien hable español no se sentía
suficientemente cómodo como para dar una
entrevista en nuestra lengua pero habla
este astronauta canadiense y como decía
pablo tiene formación de médico pues
justamente y para eso voy en esto él
médico en el centro de salud y nules lic
en subir en itú quebec y que por qué
digo esto porque trabajaba como médico
en esas comunidades alejadas del norte
con los inuit y antes de ir al espacio
había pedido expresamente a un artista y
knoc y de intuit de nuna dic que es el
lejano norte que verse y que le diseñara
algo especial de las de la nación y nuit
para que él llevara y finalmente a él
cuando se fue al espacio se llevó una
pieza de arte inuit
y objetos simbólicos de la nación
micmacs de nueva escocia eso expresión
muy interesante y esas son cosas que van
a quedar en la estación espacial y
entonces lo que llevó concretamente la
diseñadora y nook se llama victoria pic
y le diseñó una pulsera de piel de foca
preciosa
estamos viendo le diseñó dos y una creo
que se quedó la esposa de david sanz ya
que le gustó tanto que ella se quedó con
una y la otra él
llegó al espacio y también la de la otra
diseño
la otra artista que es sana francis le
dio una pluma de águila y una sexta
miniatura hecha de madera de un árbol de
fresno negro que se lo puede ver también
aquí entonces me pareció extraordinaria
esta historia de que las primeras
naciones canadienses estén en este
increíble
si es la primera vez que tengamos tantas
en tanto amor y tanto respeto por los
símbolos materiales porque en realidad
representan lo que uno quiere que
representen me llama la atención y que
ahora eso que nosotros le damos respeto
y tiene un valor importante estén ahí
arriba es increíble estar en la estación
espacial internacional pues es increíble
a sí y bueno y la pluma que esta pluma
de águila que es un elemento clave en
todas las personas y todas las primeras
naciones y asia de norteamérica de
américa latina en todos lados hay una
pluma porque es el águila es bueno más
norteamérica sobre todo porque es el
águila norteamérica claro exacto la
cabeza blanca bueno entonces eso a mí me
gusta mucho esa pulsera lástima que
averiguar esta artista donde trabajan
nuestros astronautas además es vecino de
la ribera sur
ah
bueno muy bien y lo que justamente estas
artistas una de ellas que es de halifax
la que les regaló la que le hizo la
pluma y la cesta ella contaba que
también recibió una invitación especial
para ir a un lugar en halifax desde
donde iban a ver el lanzamiento de la
nave espacial entonces ella estuvo ahí
acá en montreal estaba la otra artista
de montreal que es de nuna vic y estaba
aquí en montreal con la esposa de los
astros ante el astronauta en fin había
muchísima gente entonces además que la
estación espacial internacional puede
verse a simple vista
en noches muy despejadas si no se lo ve
pasar muy lentamente y hay un mapa que
se estrellas tendrían que ser muy claro
entonces no hay un mapa que muestra cuál
es el recorrido en el momento real ahí
ubicándose con este mapa uno puede
buscar la porción del cielo por donde
debería pasar en ese momento y se la
puede ver se ve una lucecita muy
hay una aplicación que no voy a decir el
nombre pero que nos permite poner y ese
es el ángel
exacto el nombre conocido
internacionalmente la sigla y le pone
localizar y va una flechita indicando en
qué parte del cielo
no puedo dar ninguna marca comercial de
hecho en la página de la nasa hay un
mapa que muestra el espacio apuesta
interesante muy bien no sé si tenemos si
tengo un saludo aquí en realidad más
flexionar día que está hecho ya saludos
amigos hablando de accidentes de
tránsito hoy dice en ecuador es una
tendencia el hashtag que genere general
torres genera y barceló caja general
torres un ciudadano en estado de
ebriedad que ocasiona un choque y se
resiste a ser detenido a pretexto ese
dijo el general de policía se hace falta
en estas épocas en especial hacer un
llamado atención a no conducir bajo
efectos del alcohol y nosotros le
sumamos aquí en canadá que ahora
se puede comprar tranquilamente sin
ningún tipo de problema marihuana que
efecto a la marihuana también en las
últimas horas en donde en la
municipalidad long en la ribera sur fue
detenida una conductora de taxis que
estaba estaba conduciendo valor bajo los
efectos de la marihuana guau
hoy mismo está esta noticia la escuché
esta mañana que decía que ahora la
policía puede detener a una persona de
tener un auto y hacerle el auto y hacer
el arco test es una norma federal que
entra en vigencia el 18 de diciembre a
partir de 18 edición de la policía puede
obligar a cualquier persona que sospeche
de estar bajo los efectos de sustancias
tóxicas
se puede obligar al conductor a
someterse a los análisis de sustancias
tóxicas eso va generando una especie de
cuidado
para eso está nariz roja también es
decir bueno se van se van acumulando una
serie de cosas y no se nos olvida que
acá tenemos un invierno muy complicado y
sumado a los riesgos de consumir
sustancias tóxicas ya la conducción
sobre la nieve y el hielo
no agreguemos más factores para hacer
más posible un accidente esperemos que
llegar a casa
[Risas]
pero pocos tomar lo que quieras pero
llamarán
y si no tiene ganas
vamos entonces no nos queda muchísimo
tiempo vamos a hablar de los temas que
destacamos esta semana a leonardo vos
tienes algo de qualcomm que dice que la
mayoría de los teléfonos android serán
compatibles con 5 eje en 2019 es aquí
con 5g qué quiere decir esto en realidad
nosotros estamos en nuestros teléfonos
hoy la mayoría del mundo utiliza 4g como
digamos velocidad que es un estándar de
transmisión de datos o lte esas son las
dos simples bueno lo que se viene
diciendo hace rato hace un tres o cuatro
años atrás particularmente es la
posibilidad de entrar en él
en el tipo de comunicación 5g digamos
que es avanzado que vaya nuevo cien
veces más rápido lo haremos ahora pero
bueno evidentemente no solamente poner
las torres para emitir en 5g sino que
las los dispositivos tengan la capacidad
de recibirlo y bueno en este caso cual
con que es una gran empresa
internacional con base en eeuu que
producen microchips acaba de sacar su
microchip de para recibir en teléfonos
celulares este tipo de transmisión en 5g
y lo interesante es que ya hay empresas
que están avanzadas como la china huawei
que desplazó a por como segundo vendedor
de teléfonos celulares es increíble no
samsung ex ya omic es otra empresa china
que vende teléfonos realmente muy
baratos ellos ya dicen que para el 2019
van a tener por lo menos un dispositivo
con capacidad 5g y el problema de esto
para apodos que no viene muy bien es que
acaba de salir su responsable de
comunicaciones diciendo que ellos
hasta entre un año y medio por lo menos
no es decir que aquel que compra por
este año el año que viene y producción
probablemente el otro caramba
desplegadas las redes 5g probablemente
en ese tipo de transmisión de datos pues
desgracias leonardo y bosé luis nos vas
nos nos vas a explicar qué quiere decir
debemos definir a qué llamamos
integración del inmigrante porque esto
es bueno exactamente hace pocos días la
nueva administración de gobierno en
quebec acaba anunciar o acaba de
confirmar mejor dicho un recorte de
eliminación a parte del año próximo se
van a recibir un alrededor de un 20%
menos de inmigrantes esto preocupa a
diversas entidades y organismos entre
ellos a la mesa de concertación de
organismos al servicio de las personas
refugiadas e inmigrantes que critican la
medida del gobierno no porque el
gobierno no tenga derecho el gobierno la
sociedad que ve que en su cadencia en
general no tienen derecho a debatir la
inmigración a si quieren o no tener
inmigración sino porque entiende esta
mesa que hablar solamente de cifras no
involucra a un tema tan complicado como
la inmigración en los términos que
debería ser
y teme la mesa de concertación que
además esta medida del gobierno afecte
solamente a los sectores más vulnerables
acaba de anunciar el primer ministro
françois lego que se va a recortar un
20% la inmigración económica pero
anunció que es su voluntad también
incluir en el año próximo a refugiados y
a gente que está involucrada en el rango
de reunificación familiar esos son dos
sectores que la mesa define como
vulnerables y además sostienen nuestra
entrevistada que se llama verónica islas
el hecho de bajar la cantidad de
inmigración no va a bajar la cantidad de
postulantes entonces lo que va a tener
como resultado es un alargamiento de los
procesos de también ya se vienen
criticando desde hace tanto tiempo
porque nada nos afecta y apuesta como
deberían rápidamente por último porque
no nos queda casi tiempo reclama
veronica islas debatir que se trata que
o de qué se habla cuando se habla de
integración porque yo creo que la
integración pronunciar y no el primer
ministro luego en cuando hizo su campaña
electoral había dicho de que hay un
problema acá seré quebec recibe quiero
recibir este año 50 mil inmigrantes pero
hay problemas
integrarlos y que por eso iba a bajar la
barra de 10.000 personas menores los
inmigrantes llegaron aquí elegidos por
el gobierno es un perfil de formación
profesional y laboral y también de
experiencia de conocimiento lingüístico
y entonces si los inmigrantes llegados
aquí no encuentran trabajo no es por
culpa los inmigrantes algo que está
fallando exactamente que había que ir a
buscar qué pasa exactamente y entonces y
la clasificación de los inmigrantes
también habría que poner más mayor
énfasis también en eso
en un ambiente pues más desarrollado a
veces 6 dicen 6 meses te damos seis
meses de formación es desconocimiento de
los títulos hay muchas cosas que están
pero por ejemplo del campo de la lengua
que es uno de los puntos claves de la
política de luego hay ejemplos claros y
nuestros lugares de formación
lingüística en el ámbito laboral
entonces no es necesario aprender el
idioma para después lanzarse atrás
gracias luis leonardo vos querías
agregar algo no nos digamos sigamos
porque nos queda poco tiempo hablando no
no importa quería decir algo o no había
uno ahora digo algo
con respeto que les lleva poco tiempo
contreras rincón dice buenas tardes
saludos desde barranquilla colombia
feliz día de las velitas para todos
no esta noche del 7 al 8 es el día de
las velitas en barranquilla se prenden
velas y todo el mundo y bien vela y pues
muy chico de ron
blancos y saludos a mi prima negra ester
barrios que nos está escuchando esto le
gusta colombia en estos dos saludos y
bien yo quería resaltar si es por cuba y
un escritor quebequense exacto es un
escritor quebequense que se llama
frederic la uah y que ganó este año el
premio del gobernador general con su
libro y la gobernadora general bueno en
este caso de la gobernadora general que
es antes del después viajes a cuba con
george orwell entonces resulta que eso
fue en el 2016 que él estuvo en
cuba y que cuando estuvo en cuba que fue
más o menos el mismo momento en que
barack obama estuvo visitó y que hubo
este estadista entonces él fue allá y
frederick la boa y se encontró con que
se había reeditado o se había publicado
en 1984 de george orwell entonces él no
comprendía cómo así que en cuba que era
un régimen en ese momento autoritario
por decirlo de alguna forma se podía
publicar un libro como 1984 de george
orwell que es tantito tiene
totalitarismo cosa ésta no entonces pues
es toda la trama ese es el de su libro
con el que se ganó el premio el
gobernador general y éste él estuvo pues
la entrevista es un ensayo entonces
persigue la traza y entrevistó a
personas del gobierno y al y al editor y
ahora a la compañía estatal que publica
los libros también en cuba en fin ese es
el se titula el viajes a cuba con george
orwell es entonces está en el sitio web
ese y net punto sea y a mí ya no me
tiene que dar un poquito del tiempo
el reportaje que yo destacó es que nos
costará este año a todos los canadienses
en el 2019 comer mucho más caro y que ya
sea en la casa o en restaurantes los
alimentos se van a subir muchísimo y no
sé si ustedes y bueno hay que ver por
qué y aquí explica es un informe
canadiense sobre precios de los
alimentos que lo hacen todos los años y
ese informe pronostica que bueno hay que
prepararse para un gran aumento de
factura en los comestibles y también
dice que por otro lado que hay noticias
positivas respecto a esto habrá que ver
de qué se trate a que lo veo es que la
también los mariscos bajan y ustedes se
acordarán el año pasado a mí eso me
acuerdo cuando fui a un mercado que está
cerca de mi casa un coliflor a 8 dólares
un coliflor chiquito encima 8 dólar y
que tuviéramos en una gota técnica más o
menos se vienen esos mismos precios yo
ya me doy cuenta en los mercados y hasta
el coliflor lo voy siguiendo hasta
cuatro dólares de queriendo llegar a
cinco y todavía no estamos en pleno
invierno así que ajustarse los bolsillos
foto me encanta esa foto le tiene esa
hambre esa foto no volveremos todos
carnívoros no pero dicen que la
tendencia es que está disminuyendo por
eso está bajando el precio de la carne
porque la gente come menos carne en
canadá es importado aumentando los
frutos solamente porque eso sí no baja
la demanda bien entonces eso es todo por
esta semana gracias por habernos
acompañado cariños y saludos a todos y
nos damos cita a la próxima semana con
el castor cibernética de las velitas
ustedes